[Musique]
il fait tout le temps la gueule comme
seul ouais ça va faire trois membres
[Musique]
il
quelqu'un a une idée
ouais j'ai il pourrait se marier
ok avec une meuf une bonne meuf genre
ariane massenet mais dans un kebab pas
dans vos sandwichs dans le restaurant et
à ce moment-là entrerait par la fenêtre
des poulets je ferai tout de suite je
les remercie c'est mon stop il sait ne
rien dire on s'en fout
l'autre quand il va se réveiller de -20
il n'y a pas trace qui pourra comme
d'hab et ouais pourquoi pas un rêve de
cul c'est facile à faire et puis ça fait
toujours plaisir
bon moi j'ai peut-être un truc alors
attendez parce que si c'est pour me
battre comme à chaque fois
alors vous me connaissez moi j'aime bien
les trucs un peu dark tout ça du coup
j'avais pensé un rêve sur la mort de son
père
et comme tous mes tatouages on va faire
comment on fait d'habitude on lit la
liste de ce qu'il a vécu ce qu'il a
pensé à la journée on s'en inspire et
puis voilà on va avoir un petit problème
parce qu'il n'ya pas grand chose le plus
gros événement de la journée c'est quand
il a maté les nichons de la question de
monoprix et qui s'est dit qui a été
bonne pour se faire une raison
son quotidien il n'est pas intéressant
son taf le soul il n'a pas de meuf la
padanie potiche a pas de quoi le petit
chat oui d'accord enfin c'est quoi le
rapport
les paires et comportant comme un ami
avec un des poils sais pas du tout ce
que j'ai essayé d'amener essaie d'amener
un fou moyen d'un petit coin d'y amener
sur tous et c'est juste du schisme déjà
parce que toi tu préfères forcément
avoir une chauve souris ne font
dégueulasse avec une frange qui écoutent
de la musique qu'ils écoutent du quillio
c'est ça sortait de padoue
le mec étant dax de uche quoi mais en
même temps comment ça se fait qu'on y
arrive est vachement bien avant le sais
pas ça fait longtemps qu'on suit en plus
et c'est ça souviens plus c'est ça c'est
ce que j'aime lire en fête
on n'a pas le droit d'être ici mais toi
c'est vraiment bon peut quoi c'est de la
mort la mort la mort la mort la mort la
mort la mort du p o
non non non non non et à ce moment là la
glissière du mode hop on n'a qu'à
l'appeler a dit elle prend la carte est
bien frotter la carte sur le liban faire
un truc sur son père mais ce sont les
moines de minutes pour vous expliquer
jacques pas faire un truc super l'attend
ah oui et pour ma part ça tout de suite
et caissiers intéressant là dedans 1
à l'enterrement possible la maladie oui
ça doit vous faire ça j'imagine les
week-ends à l'hosto l'américiane oui on
va nous faire passer d'une magnifique à
se gausser ya basta laissez moi vous
expliquer
[Musique]
je suis désolé j'ai vu au client sait
rien on risque d'être rude où on fait
quoi parce que moi j'ai péché que rien
compris mais coûte
on l'écouté on forme un travail tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]